[Music]
the remake of Stephen King's it was
released in September 2017 and we
couldn't wait to see it and if you are a
fan who already read the book you
probably noticed some things that the
others will never see if not we're here
to tell you what you missed make sure
you watch this video until the end to
see what the end of the movie revealed
about what is coming next follow us we
have fun secrets hiding down here if you
love horror movies as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you small details in it that
only true fans noticed the original
clown Stephen King's it was a success
since 1990 and the movie was also
followed by a TV mini-series as soon as
we watched the trailer we knew that some
things were going to be really similar a
boy gave a boat to his little brother
and he put on his raincoat to play
outside under the rain unfortunately the
boat was swept into a storm drain and
this is when their little boy saw the
clown Pennywise and disappeared however
you will notice that the clown was a
little different this time even if he
was in the dark that's because the new
director Andy machete
reimagined him differently and he is
even more terrifying we didn't forget
the original cloud and Andy remembers
him too this is why you can see Tim
Curry's Pennywise and one of the most
memorable scenes in the film when Richie
is trapped in a room full of clouds in
the house one of the dolls is clearly
modeled after the original Pennywise and
he is right there at the left of the
screen don't worry if you didn't see it
the first time you can still be a fan of
the movie we had to watch it a second
time to really pay attention to the
dolls during this terrifying moment the
80s
shirts you really need to be a fan of
Stephen King to see all the references
in the movie and this time you'll have
to look at the shirts of different
characters the most obvious reference to
a movie was even seen in the trailer can
you guess what the car with razor-sharp
teeth on Eddy's shirt is it is Christine
herself from another Stephen King movie
you can also see Bill wearing a tracker
brothers t-shirt if you read the novel
you know that it is a local shipping
company based in the fictional town
of dairy in the novel this is where the
adult Eddie first sees the new Pennywise
some fans also think that Richie's
freezes shirt is a reference to Stephen
King's real-life home as the company
really existed but there is one last
shirt that only the biggest horror fans
could see just take a look at Bell
chuggins wearing a shirt featuring the
band anthrax with the words follow me or
die in the back these are actually the
lyrics from the song among the living
which the band wrote about the stabbed
another book from Stephen King and we
heard that we could see more eighties
shirts paying homage to movies like The
Shining carry and Pet Sematary make sure
you tell us where they are if you can
see it the fears in the movie we
understand that all the members of the
losers Club have phobias the Pennywise
preys upon if you read the novel you
know that this is why it likes to
terrorize children by taking the form of
old Universal movie monsters it includes
the Wolfman Frankenstein monster The
Creature from the Black Lagoon and the
mummy however as the movie was set in
the 80s instead of the 50s some of these
fears had to be adapted to this decade
director Andy machete said that many of
these monsters wouldn't appear in the
movie and will be replaced by new forms
that's because he wanted to make the
terrors surprising even for those who
have read the book but it seems like he
changed his mind because we can see
these monsters for a moment in the movie
for example you can see that the
creature does briefly attack Ben in the
form of the mummy
during the losers final battle as a
reference to the novel but that's not
all if you have ever been wondering what
Ritchie's personal fear was you might be
surprised to learn that it was actually
revealed not only in the movie but also
in the trailer don't you think that
penny wisest hand is a little hairy
that's because Ritchie is afraid of
werewolves and it takes his form the
balloon the red balloon is something
that we immediately recognize when
Pennywise is near by something so
innocent shouldn't be so threatening
unless you know what is coming next
whether it is in a classroom next to an
abandoned house or in a car we have
never been so terrified of something so
childish and so simple however this
balloon is
complicated than what you might think
when Patrick was lured by penny once and
saw the red balloon you could read the
phrase I heart Derry if you didn't
understand it you are not the only one
and know the scary clown didn't mean
that he liked to live in this town it is
actually a reference to the novel in the
second chapter of the book a gay man
named Adrian melon passed away when he
was the victim of a homophobic hate
crime at the dairy carnival there was a
Hart dairy merchandise everywhere and he
was wearing an I heart Derry hat when he
took his last breath you won't be happy
to hear that it was even inspired by a
real crime
but anyway Patrick himself is a closeted
homosexual in the novel and this could
be a way to show that these similar
characters won't be alive for a long
time so beware next time you see a red
balloon coming out of nowhere
Pennywise might be watching you the last
losers after being terrified for two
hours we couldn't believe that it was
already the end of the movie this time
the losers were standing in a circle
holding hands and they swore that they
would come back to Derry as adults if
Pennywise came back and if you closely
paid attention to who left the circle
first you might already know what is
going to happen in the sequel the first
one to leave is stamp and if you read
the book you know that he is the first
one who ends his life then there's Eddie
who will pass away in the final battle
with the creature at least bill and
Beverley will be happy to hear about
that because they were the last two to
leave the circle but we will have to
watch the sequel to know if this theory
was right if you read the novel you know
that the first line of the story hints
that Pennywise might still be alive
but plenty wise swore that he would
never write about him again because the
character is too scary even for him so
that means that all we could have left
is another movie are you a fan you
noticed another small detail in the
movie don't be shy to tell us what it is
in the comments section down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for small details in it that only
true fans notice for more stories like
this make sure you watch 10 cartoon
secrets finally revealed thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]